i'm gonna do something i don't usually
do on this channel and i'm gonna get
into some personal anecdotes so a few
months ago i quit a data science job and
this isn't the first time that i've done
it either
in this video i'm gonna talk about my
reasons for quitting both times i'm
richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
now i'm going to clarify that i did
switch to another job and today i am
still working as a data scientist but i
have caught myself thinking especially
over the last couple years or so that i
don't know that that will necessarily be
the case forever
so in this video i am going to talk
about my reasons for quitting but then
we'll come back at the end and talk a
little bit more about the super
long-term prospects for me anyway of
data science before i do that though
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and take just a fraction of a
second to smash the like button because
that really does help my content reach a
larger audience also if you guys would
be willing to go above and beyond to
support i will have links in the
description of this video to my paypal
and patreon accounts as well as my
crypto wallet addresses all right so the
first reason i'm going to talk about is
the industries i was working in
so for almost seven years i had either
freelance engagements contracts or
full-time jobs in the healthcare or
pharmaceutical industries now at the
time anyway this made a lot of sense to
me because those are just industries
that i care about and that i'm the most
interested in i always figured if i can
leverage a data skill set to improve
hospital performance or patient outcomes
that's making a really positive mark on
the universe and it's a really amazing
thing
but there are some definite pros and
cons that come with being in any
industry and i think that's true for any
field whether that's data science or not
and definitely one thing that kept
coming up for me again and again was
regulation now here in the u.s we have
what's called the health insurance
portability and accountability act of
1996
also known as hipaa this is basically a
law that creates privacy standards
around what's called patient health
information or phi the gist of it being
you cannot share sensitive private
patient health information without that
patient's explicit permission now this
law is quite well intentioned and i'm
not here to discuss the merits either
for or against it in fact i'm pretty
sure any of us who have been in any kind
of
situation involving medical treatment
don't want our information being shared
with a ton of other people either it's
also not unique to the us there's
similar regulations in europe and in
india and in many other places but from
the perspective of somebody trying to
leverage real data in order to use it to
try and solve some kind of problem
it does create all sorts of challenges
and in fact i'd go so far as to say this
law influences every single part of data
science activity when you work in the
healthcare industry from where your data
is stored to what apis your data can
interface with to what programming
languages or workflows you're allowed to
use to what solutions are permissible
without too badly compromising patient
privacy
the list just goes on and on there's
just been so many things throughout the
years that i've wanted to do or to learn
and i haven't been able to
directly because of privacy concerns and
privacy regulation
that just after a certain point i got
the inclination just to try something
else completely different
the next thing that's sort of
contributed to me quitting my data
science jobs is technologies so any
place where you might go to work
professionally as a data scientist is
going to have a well-defined
technological stack unless it's just in
complete startup territory and it's just
figuring this out
for example your company may use a
combination of let's say r with shiny
and power bi
or maybe your company has a fully
cloud-based tech stack that relies uh
first then on jupiter notebooks with
python kernels but my point is for the
most part this tech stack is going to be
pretty fixed and it's not going to
change much thing is you're going to get
stuck doing one kind of thing for a
little while
and that may be totally okay with you
but the overall problem with that is
in data science there's such a massive
breadth of skills that the market may
expect you to know and problem is
if you allow yourself to get light on
years of experience or just a little bit
rusty on various important skills
you may be putting yourself at a
long-term competitive disadvantage and
just for me i've gone so heavy on r over
the last several years that i just
wanted to switch gears and take a break
from it and switch to a more python
heavy environment and that's what i've
been doing i've actually only used r a
couple times in the last six months or
so and i'm starting to miss it so what
are you gonna do then the next reason
i'm gonna talk about here is network
expansion this is a pretty nuanced
conversation and it's going to look
slightly different for pretty much
everybody
but something that you learn after a few
years of experience is that professional
networking is extremely important your
network is going to be one of the best
possible resources for learning new
skills let's face it there's always
going to be somebody out there who knows
something that you don't and personally
more jobs than not for me have come from
people whom i had just met or whom i
already knew
so your network is also an incredible
tool for discovering new opportunities
now leaving companies for me can be a
little sad just because you're also
leaving your co-workers
and over time just for me there have
been certain co-workers that have become
like close friends and family you spend
more time together and then just
inevitably you build better higher
quality relationships but understand
that ultimately this is a trade-off
because the longer that you stay in one
place
the longer that you are missing out on
opportunities to meet and work with an
entirely different new set of people and
that's especially true if you're like me
and you are coming from multiple much
smaller companies so i really don't
think that there's a one-size-fits-all
approach to this
as long as you understand the value of
having a strong professional network
you're probably going to do pretty well
for yourself now let's switch gears here
and talk about something that's similar
in the sense that there's not really a
one-size-fits-all approach to it and
that's solving different kinds of
problems
and so you learn very early in data
science that there's way more problems
out there than you could possibly have
the time if you had your whole life to
try to solve frankly that's because
every company in the world out there has
some kind of business problem that they
haven't optimally solved yet
there's also companies more and more
taking advantage of the amount of data
that they have so you put two and two
together that's why there are so many
things for data scientists to do and why
i don't think you'll ever run into a job
security problem if you have a strong
data science skill set and i have to say
i have caught myself in a few different
spells where i just felt like i was
working on the same kind of problem over
and over again there were a few
instances where that was highly specific
machine learning rabbit holes sometimes
it was r shiny or general dashboard
development
it can be various different things now
if you work at a larger company this is
probably a little less likely to be an
issue for you because you probably have
a little bit more room to sort of move
around and try different things but for
me variety really is the spice of life
i'm a person who can get easily bored
and i have to be moving around a little
bit trying different things to keep
myself entertained and then there was a
fifth reason for me and it's the
simplest one of all i'm talking of
course about money it's a fact that the
largest raises you'll ever get are when
you switch jobs
usually these raises are somewhere
between 10 to 20 percent
and the average
is estimated to be about 14.8 percent
and i have to be honest i don't love
that this is the case i do sort of like
the idea of loyalty at least to some
extent but with inflation in the united
states at a 40-year high right now you
simply have to be making large
aggressive raises every year in order to
keep up with it
and i really do suspect this is a pretty
strong driving factor for the great
resignation that we're seeing right now
now i would strongly suggest against
trying to game this system because let's
be honest companies aren't stupid and if
you're getting a new job every single
year they know exactly what you're doing
but the other side of it though is
if you stay at one company for your
entire life you are going to leave the
biggest possible raises you could ever
get off the table so i've given you five
different reasons why i quit my data
science jobs
however i do still have love for the
field of data science it's rewarding
it's exciting i maintain that it's a
field that's not going anywhere in the
future and in fact i get more and more
convinced of that every single year but
i also have to be honest am i going to
be a data scientist forever
i don't know i can't answer that
question working on different problems
in different industries meeting new
people learning new tech and moving up
the income ladder are all things that
have helped to keep this field fresh and
exciting for me but i don't have a
crystal ball i don't necessarily know
where all my passions are going to be 10
years from now and data science isn't
the only thing that i like i have a
couple different videos where i talk
about the long-term trajectory for data
scientists and i think often it comes
down to getting a little bit closer to
the business and closer to managing
people
rather than learning new tech and that's
probably where i see myself going after
a certain point too ultimately i don't
really see data science as an end in and
of itself but rather as a means towards
just innovating people's lives and
business through new products and
services
and just seeing that bigger picture is
one of those things that's kept the
field interesting to me for so long
that's why i think it's always important
to know what opportunities are out there
and to do research don't waste time
working on things that you know aren't a
good fit for you have some good quality
information and use that to make the
best possible decisions for you so i'll
leave it there thanks for watching this
video if you enjoyed it take a moment to
smash the like button
and also leave me a comment down below
have you quit a job in the last year if
so how'd you feel about it
did it feel really good did you regret
it instantly let me know down below then
i'll see you all in the not so distant
future until then
richard on data